making this video for a friend of mine
named rich rich is on an important
mission to try to inspire people to live
their best life possible and change the
world for the better and he's been
making a whole bunch of videos and great
content but he's been too afraid to put
it on his facebook page because his
friends watch it and he's afraid of how
his friends might judge him and he
thinks that they might laugh at him and
make fun of him and I said rich these
are your friends mainly here to support
you they want to see rise up they want
to see you be successful and for
whatever reason he has this big fear
that his friends just won't support him
and won't believe in what he's doing and
so wanted to make this video to support
rich hopefully his friends support this
as well I did a quick interview with him
and at the end of it I'd love to know
what you think and show a little bit of
support throw some love too too too rich
so I've decided to do a series on fear
video series after oh i'll be talking
from people that have achieved higher or
bigger than normal things and ask them
about fear therefore your experiences
and how they got through it and put it
together to a series to help other
people out there that have fears and
want to get through them to hear it from
other people that have done my friends
yeah whoever is watching and has input
feel free to put it in the comments any
questions you might want me to ask other
people but their fear is not I get
through it and things that are maybe
personal to you that maybe you want to
get through or overcome post those in
the comments or send me messages and
i'll add them to the list of questions
that i asked i'm curious and i'm
interested myself because whatever fear
you have sits there in the back your
mind and kind of distorts everything
else you trying to do and
actually the end the way for you to
accomplish whatever it is you want to
accomplish and I started in with Evan
who's behind the camera and he's forcing
me twisted my own enforcing it to get in
front of the camera because he knows
that that's my fear being in front of
the camera and talking another friend of
mine Sean move it to me Sean mosin you
said you know I do things all the time
that I'm afraid of you feel the fear and
you do it anyways so I guess your nose
where did this fear of other people's
opinions come from tell me one story of
what I know that this is this really is
one I'm so the hatred for today one
that's easy to remember was it about
dancing I think was in high school days
school dance whatever was club bar
whatever dancing and someone a friend
made a comment about me not knowing how
to dance which was truly annoying what i
was doing whatever my thing and that
kind of shut down and i stopped and next
time i tried maybe same thing happened
and i just said forget about it it's all
good i'll just have no I drink or figure
out a way to get around dancing what are
you afraid of posting us on facebook
well I guess I'm afraid of the whole
buzz or the people are going to think
badly of it or going to laugh at it be
I'll be embarrassed by it wrong regret
because that's the the noise in my head
probably not true here is holding me
back from doing more personal videos
from maybe cuz I'm a photographer and
filmmaker something from creating more
personal serious photos films because I
know that whatever you create is a piece
of you in there and people always
interpret that it's about yours piece of
me there and you know I don't want that
out there so laughter is probably
holding me back for more meaningful work
inspiring something that has more about
mmm deeper not
fishing what is what has inspired me to
you inspire is anything that inspires
you to evolve to change the row to move
and not for a minute but maybe forever
make sure to check out my nose latter ya
gotta laughing hi I'm Jason j-rod
fonseka of ra's online com and i want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and XD only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period